[Applause]
oh
they're trying to bring people in three
at a time they're trying to bring them
in
through the back door they're trying to
make sure that people have access
but there's only so much that they can
do when the president of this university
who shut down this event in the first
place
because he's a totalitarian when he
refuses to stand up for basic principles
of free speech in this country
there are people today who are saying
that we won we won the university backed
down an hour before this happened
and uncanceled the speech they never had
the right to cancel in the first place
no one won anything when there's a group
of folks outside who can't get in
because they're a bunch of totalitarian
authoritarian racists who won't let
anyone in who disagrees with their point
of view
with that said i'm going to give this
speech i'm going to say what i have to
say
and then we'll see what happens outside
the pathetic president of this
university wrote when he canceled this
event earlier this week or tried to
cancel it because i wasn't going to go
along
with his ridiculous notions of what
diversity constitutes diversity means
that he gets to approve any speech that
happens on this campus
which is precisely what stalin thought
diversity meant here's what william
covino said quote
after careful consideration i have
decided
i have decided that it will be best for
our campus community
he's decided it'll be best for you i
mean come on if we reschedule ben
shapiro's appearance
for a later date so that we can arrange
for him to appear as part of a group of
speakers
with differing viewpoints and diversity
such an event will better represent
our university's dedication to the free
exchange of ideas
and the value of considering multiple
viewpoints you can hear how well this
free exchange of ideas is going when
there are people
literally standing outside pushing down
reporters like adele nazarian of
breitbart
assaulting people outside threatening
acts of violence to prevent people from
hearing a dissenting point of view
that's free exchange of ideas
on america's college campuses that's
free exchange of ideas thanks to the
american left
that's free exchange of ideas thanks to
william covino
and his thug rule here the value of
considering multiple viewpoints
how about this viewpoint let people say
what they're going to say
is that so rough
and again folks if you're watching on
the live stream the waves of students
that you see entering right now are
being sneaked in
because in america in 2016 you have to
use the back door if you want to
participate in free speech you get to
block the front door if you're a member
of the left and this is how it's written
you and there it is gang
[Music]
guess what you know what
they're not going to stop us
[Applause]
folks if you're just joining the live
stream somebody pulled the fire alarm to
stop this because this is how the
fascists do it
[Applause]
that it is literally a threat to life
and limb to go out there i've told that
i've been told that they can't
personally guarantee my security or any
of your securities that's why if you go
out there right now
well not fine with me because i don't
want to see anybody get hurt or killed
out there for typically not the good
guys so
if that's the case here's what's going
to happen i actually have to take a
secret way out
seriously with police escort it's
america 2016. it's unbelievable
okay and uh and then the assumption by
the cops is the assumption by the police
officers is
that these crowds will eventually
disperse and you'll have a safe way out
i've been told that if you try to get
out right now
you could be in a situation where you
walk up behind these people and they
refuse to let you out they'll stop
any active active battery upon you
they'll stop
people from punching you or they'll act
after someone has punched you more
likely because they can't
see the future but you know but they
can't guarantee
if you go out right now you're actually
going to be safe
so i mean for folks who are watching
this online people who know what's going
on nationally
this is america now this is america now
okay and this is not a matter of
cowardice we're not stepping into a mob
of 300
angry people out there the cowardice is
this administration that allows this
garbage and evil to go on
[Applause]
[Music]
all across the country who believes in
free speech who believes in free
assembly who believes in the
constitution of the united states of
liberty
i'm calling on you to look at what's
happening out here watch what's
happening out here
recognize that when the students cannot
be guaranteed safety on their own campus
from people
who are outside whipping mob into a
frenzy over
basic principles of free speech it's
time to stand up
it's time to fight it's time to become
part of a movement
enough is enough
stand up we all stand together the
constitution the united states for
liberty for freedom
be safe out there and my personal email
address in case you want to get in touch
with me any of you this is over the
internet too my personal email address
is b
shapiro at dailywire.com if you need
help if you need coverage if you need
media coverage
we're going to organize a movement
because this cannot stand this
cannot scan
[Applause]